you go to the mainstream for a dating
advice say and it's garbage it's just be
yourself
it's like it's just this disney fired
nonsense you're me don't worry you'll
meet someone eventually like fate will
take care of it just be yourself just be
nice
and then you you go to the college party
or something and it isn't the nice the
nice guys who are like hooking up with
the with the with the with the girls
that you're into or whatever it's and
it's then you you feel like you've been
lied to and then you go in search of
pickup artistry or the manosphere or
you you look for things outside of the
mainstream because it feels like the
mainstream is
either lying to you with some agenda or
just some lack of understanding and then
you gravitate to alternatives and some
of those alternatives are
not necessarily good for you you can
become radicalized by that
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissinger
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant and returning guest
today is a journalist and author james
bloodworth welcome back man lovely to be
back it's been a few years since we had
you on we talked about one of your books
which was hired and that was about how
big companies abused staff particularly
we talked about amazon and uber and
others and you've been writing a lot of
stuff since you've written another book
and of course you're working on another
one and you've written a lot of articles
and one of the areas of focus i think
has been particularly masculinity dating
all that sort of stuff so it's good to
have you back uh we wanted to talk to
you about dating first of all because
that is the world that neither of us is
particularly involved in anymore we're
in cells
yeah we've upgraded uh so
uh
it seems to me just as an outside
observer reading about it and seeing
that the the way the technology has
changed that whole aspect of life has
just been extraordinary tell us about
that yes i mean i think dating apps have
changed uh the romantic sphere in the
same way that social media is changing
politics and we hear a lot about how
social media is changing politics how
social media has made us more
adversarial say twitter the way we
behave on twitter we don't necessarily
behave in real life i think dating apps
are uh
changing the way the technology we see
is just this tool that we use that we
that we input our desires into the into
the dating app um into the into our
smartphone and then that just it just
comes out the other other end and
selects those people for us whereas i
think as we've learned with other forms
of technology the technology itself
shapes the uh the thing that comes out
the other side so it's not just a kind
of neutral platform it actually um
funnels our kind of desires into these
narrower directions or it actually
changes the way we interact with each
other quite profoundly because romance
is obviously you know a central central
part of people's lives and so i don't
think we take that uh issue seriously
enough and and when you talk about these
changes what is happening because one of
our former guest mike driver is a
business guy and he was just saying
you know one of the things that will
happen as a result of dating apps is
you're going to get different people
matching up together and getting married
and having children than you would have
done in the past so you're actually
going to get
different people being in relationships
than you would have done in the past but
what are the impact is it having because
you know we talk about twitter and
politics it's very clear i think that
social media is having a hugely
detrimental impact on our ability to
have conversations and all of that
what's been the impact on on on dating
and romance uh from those apps i think
the the first thing that dating app
technology does is it basically
formalizes preferences which
may have been arbitrary before or they
may not have had like central importance
so we see something we see this with
with both men and women so
we see for example
women having a preference uh very
commonly on apps for men six foot you
know there's a setting six foot or over
there's even um racial preferences on
some apps or there have been in the past
where people can screen out uh people of
different different ethnicities which we
can all see how that could be
potentially problematic that's the one
for me
but it's um i mean the author mia
leviton wrote a really interesting book
about uh tinder and she went on lots and
lots of uh tinder dates to write this
book and she said you know if you put
all the people she'd uh ever dated in
real life on an app she'd probably um
swipe right is it you know she'd
probably reject uh most of them because
there was something different there was
it was the chemistry or something else
it wasn't these arbitrary criteria so i
think trying to kind of funnel
uh our dating preferences through
through those narrow criteria that can
bring lots of resentment so we see that
in some of the
in-cell community for example in in the
manosphere
where
because in the past those those kind of
there were those kind of areas where
you could meet someone more organically
those those especially with the pandemic
those those things have kind of um have
been kind of rolled back to some extent
it's harder to do that and we're
encouraged to do everything through a
smartphone app everything through a
dating app it will organize our lives
through these apps
and
that can be much harder for if you don't
know how to present yourself for example
if you don't have an online brand or
something and can't sell yourself online
very well like that or you don't match
some of these arbitrary criteria then
it can lead to lots of resentment and we
also see the volume of rejection
so dating apps on the one hand there is
a lower bar to i mean when i was when i
was kind of um in my late teens early
twenties i wasn't i had no success like
dating i lived in the countryside with
my grandma i was very shy um didn't
didn't do very well but i could tell
myself this story like ego protection
story that well if i wanted to if i
wanted to get a girlfriend i could if i
wanted to go and talk to that girl but
i'm just i just don't feel like it no
whereas i think with apps there's a low
bar you can put yourself on there very
easily but the sheer volume of rejection
uh it creates this kind of feedback loop
of rejection which kind of impacts that
age when you're forming an identity
so that constant negative feedback loop
i think can be very detrimental to
uh young men and women but we ten we're
tending to see the more of the
consequences from men because men tend
to act out uh when they're resentful
about things so you see like violence or
these forums with with misogyny and not
just misogyny but but people generally
men generally in a very depressed state
lamenting the their results on dating
apps
doesn't also encourage the
superficiality amongst people because
look you know everybody has their own
attributes and there are some people who
may not be as physically attracted but
they may be charismatic they may be
funny etc etc but just reducing it to a
photo i mean
that just encourages us all just to go
by what people look like yeah i think
it's uh i think dating apps and i
include instagram when i talk about this
because i think instagram in a way
is is like the world's biggest dating
app in some ways because i think uh
a lot of people use it use it in that
way and it's and dating apps kind of
came
uh around the same time and it's yeah
it's all about presentation so you could
be like a great person you could be a
you could be a great person you could
just not be photogenic for example which
is is kind of a real thing um and you
just don't know how to present yourself
uh in this new digital world through a
screen you don't have someone who can
take good photos of you you just don't
know you just don't understand that
vocabulary of how to do that and then
you're kind of left behind and yeah it
is it is arbitrary and and like you say
sometimes you meet someone and they may
not tick certain logical boxes but they
have a certain vibe or you have a
chemistry with them and that's often
more important than commonalities which
is something you tend to more select
people for
a job or something yeah and it also
incentivizes people to be dishonest
because they know for instance that if
they
say that they're ages i don't know 45
they're less likely to get dates so why
not say you're 38.
surely i mean i mean yeah it's and it's
um but again because you have these like
arbitrary
uh criteria so if i mean
i use this example because i've asked
female friends before about i asked them
about their
experience on dating apps because the
male and female experience is very
different
um
and
it's lots of them yeah they do have this
this uh
six must be six foot or whatever and
then i'll ask them hope so have you ever
dated someone shorter than this or older
or young in this and they will always
will have in real life but it's then
they kind of think about it and it's
like well but but they're getting
bombarded women typically on apps with
so much attention that
you have to filter people out some ways
so
perhaps that's why there's one last
question i want to ask which is a cross
section between dating and politics that
we've talked about because i've now seen
online like people say never date a tory
and then you've got these sort of right
of center right leaning dating platforms
do you yeah yeah they've got the right
not on them just making it
ladies
but you just go this is a recipe for
disaster in society yeah i mean i think
that's in terms of politics i think
people are forgetting how to disagree
respectfully so forgetting i had to
disagree and as we've talked about
before still be friends with someone
still still get on with someone um i
feel like i don't know what it is but i
and i don't want to just
dump on younger people but i feel like
there's please do we [ __ ] hate
i feel like people just because we're no
longer younger people sorry for this
yeah no it's true though
but i feel like it's i mean
generations you know my our generation
is true to some extent but i feel like
people are becoming worse at accepting
criticism yeah taking it as something
personal
you know it's not something you're doing
or saying it's just something it's about
you personally and i think that's um
making it much harder to disagree
respectfully so when you
uh when you look for
someone on a dating app you're looking
for someone who
shares the exact same beliefs as you do
but i also think it's
part of the
there's this idea now that romance is
it's like the disney idea that romance
is the center of everything that your
romantic partner has to fulfill every
one of your needs so you have to be able
to
um maintain like a strong sexual desire
for them
and at the same time be able to go go
home and and debate kind of marxism
leninism at the kitchen table all
evening or whatever it's like whereas
like whatever gets you hard
i think um
yeah i mean i think i think you know you
have to uh compartmentalize those things
a bit more like you shouldn't expect one
person just to fulfill every like agree
with you about everything fulfill all of
your your needs you should have
different uh yeah people for that it's
very limiting as well i mean i i
disagree with my wife and a lot of stuff
francis with his girlfriend and pretty
much everything yeah they do debate
marxism leninism a lot
um
you mentioned that the female dating
experience is very different to the male
one can you talk to us a little bit
about that
yeah so i mean
i think first of all i think well to get
take it the other the the opposite way
around i think
it is very different and i think that
leads to like a lack of empathy between
the sexes about the corresponding
experiences so
you'll see online
uh so i follow a lot of uh quite good in
cells online um part of my research i
say that but now i kind of chat to them
and befriend them but um
and you'll see them complaining and
stuff and then you'll see also lots of
women like dismiss that and say oh they
don't face like potential violence when
they're on a date and stuff which is
true but it's um
you know there's not a limit on misery
people can two groups of people can be
miserable in different ways
and with women they tend to be bombarded
with attention unwanted attention not
just on apps but in
life in general you know on the tube or
something or walking down the street
and there is due to biology the
biological fact that men are physically
stronger than women there's always on
some level that implicit like danger of
threat of violence
um which i think men often don't
understand when they when they when they
talk to women that the first thing a
woman's going to be doing is
uh trying to get a sense is if i'm alone
with this person will are they a threat
to me would they be a threat to me
um but
so that's that's one side of it
so you know woman goes on a date she has
to scream the guy is she gonna end up
with a head on a pike at the end of the
end of the night whereas i've never
thought that when i've when i've gone
out on a date um whereas men it's they
tend to
someone dating apps for example
80 of men tend to you know that's the
kind of rough figure tend to be
just getting rejections like getting one
or two matches very occasionally and
just getting just volumes and volumes of
rejection and they then transpose that
onto real life and think well
this is this is if this is the reality
on dating apps i'm never gonna i'm just
gonna be alone forever
well it's not really true because
if you don't know how to present
yourself on a dating app it doesn't mean
that
in real life which is very different you
could not meet someone and hit it off
with someone and have chemistry but
people transpose the online experience
increasingly because we spend so much of
our lives
on these apps and online to the real
world where it's not it isn't the same
but i think that's a danger and that
radicalizes lots of these men in these
um
in the in certain corners of the
manosphere
well we'll talk about that in the seg
but
we love a bit of doom and gloom here at
trigonometry but is there is there
something positive to all of this
in what sense
in any sense
is there any sense is there any way in
which about dating yeah the existence of
dating apps is making our world better
our lives easier dating you know in some
ways better is there a benefit yeah i
mean i don't think it's all bad i think
um so i've met people and had had great
time and i've met them from dating apps
and i think it allows kind of
cross-cultural um engagement as well to
some extent it allows people who are in
uh maybe a much more conservative family
setting to then branch out of that and
and see that another kind of world is
possible another experience is possible
so i do think that they
and you can also kind of hone in on what
you actually do want in a relationship
so
sometimes those preferences are aren't
arbitrary they're they're born of
experience or bad experiences or good
experiences so you can really hone in on
that and be like i do not want this and
then you can screen those people out on
a dating app so it's quite efficient um
see i don't think it's all bad but i
still think that meeting people
organically
is just much more you get a much more
accurate sense of who the other person
is and whether you find that person
attractive because the big error i think
with
thinking that dating apps will solve
uh our issues or will solve the kind of
romance question for us or make it much
more streamlined and
it's you're treating it again like it
like a job interview whereas you know
you know my my best friends you know i
could tickle the boxes about our
compatibility but it's like i don't want
to sleep with them it's like that's not
chemist that's that's a logical thing
but um
you know sexual attraction romance and
desire those things are
that's not a choice that's not like a
logical rational decision it's it's
something you feel emotionally on
which goes back to some deep biological
kind of level and it's also that the
that old adage you know opposites
attract
what you think you want in a partner
isn't necessarily the things that you
actually need for instance if you're a
you know chaotic creative person then
maybe what you actually need is someone
who's a little bit more stable a little
bit more rational a little bit more calm
even though in your heads you say i want
a creative type yeah no i think um
one benefit i think of apps funnily
enough is
they allow you to kind of play the field
a bit more if you
know if you can present yourself
okay you do okay on apps it allows you
to kind of meet more people and that's
important i think in terms of um
you don't like sometimes what you think
you like is not actually what you do
like when you like when you're younger
you think you might like something in a
partner then you meet someone with those
qualities and you realize actually as
you say it's not always necessarily
something that's beneficial to you so
but again you have to meet the people in
real life it's uh putting it just into a
filter on an app it's uh it doesn't
really get you anywhere because until
you meet someone you may they may be on
paper your perfect match but then
there'd just be no spark
hey francis do you like privacy of
course i do i don't want the feds
knowing my business in case i get
whacked because i got too close to the
truth the man is everywhere and truth
seekers like me need to be careful mate
you're a burnout former primary school
teacher who spends too much time on
miamifatincell.com
just because you read that the world is
run by cabala lizards doesn't mean it's
actually true
i've never said the world is run by a
cabal of lizards but they are definitely
tracking my online activity well if you
are worried about your data being mined
by big tech and sold off to third
parties all around the globe then start
mail is the email provider for you the
email accounts you use aren't free
they're mining your accounts and email
for data as we speak
this data can then be sold on to a whole
host of different companies start mail
keeps your messages private every email
can be encrypted even if the recipient
doesn't use encryption when you delete
an email in start mail it's gone forever
starmell uses her own service not amazon
this means they can't be put out of
business like parlour switching to start
mail is dead easy you can easily
transfer all your current email data so
you don't need to start from scratch
your cyber security has never been more
at risk email snoops and scammers have
taken advantage of the pandemic as
fishing has skyrocketed in the last year
take control of your privacy with start
mail before it's too late sign up today
and you'll get fifty percent off your
first year go to startmill.com slash
trigger that's start mail with a t
s-t-a-r-t
mail dot com forward slash trigger fifty
percent off your first year start
mail.com
trigger don't let the lizards get you
and it's also as well i i read this
statistic and
tell me if this is incorrect that people
who meet on dating apps are far more
likely to break up than if you meet in
college and if you meet in the workplace
it creates a far less stable
relationship
yeah i mean i think part of that is
there's the kind of choice paradox with
dating apps i think that that is a
an issue where the grass is always
greener potentially because
whereas in the past i think where there
was more scarcity i think scarcity is a
bad thing to view relationships with a
mentality of scarcity because
you might be you might stay in toxic
relationships then because you think i'm
never going to meet anyone else but the
flip side of that is the choice paradox
where you feel like i could just go on a
nap and meet someone else so the the
smallest kind of thing that comes up in
a relationship you just walk out the
door whereas actually if you'd
you know you have to work at every
relationship even with family members
you can't just
it's treating it like
another part of consumer capitalism that
you just have this like a product you
just throw it out when you discard it
when you've when you've had enough of it
and you don't or an upgrade it's
available yeah and i think
on it there's kind of a deeper kind of
connection that you have to build with
someone
to have a sustained relationship
and that involves working through
uh disagreements working through
things that are called sometimes red
flags because some of those things can
be worked through and actually investing
in the relationship not just treating it
as something completely disposable and
there's also the addiction element as
well because some you know
let's be fair it's quite an addictive
way to live a new experience new person
oh someone swiped left or right or
whatever it may be on my photo being
dopamine hit mm-hmm yeah and again the
big tech companies
they're not you know they don't get rich
off happily ever afters they're doing
this
to turn a profit there's so hinge you're
lying to us james what's that hinge
online potentially i mean yeah i mean
they're not they're not doing it too
it's not some altruistic thing they're
doing it to
make a profit and you know i think
we've seen the same with the gig economy
with with say when i was driving for
uber as research for the my previous
book
they gamify it to keep you out on the
road driving for longer and the apps you
know we don't know what's input into the
algorithm we don't know um
whether it's actually showing us um
who would be our most suitable matches
or whatever we know we we do know from
whistleblowers at some of the apps that
uh the algorithm you know they sometimes
game the algorithms to get us to upgrade
so when someone upgrades on an app say
to get more matches
they then stop paying the upgrade and
then they take away more of our matches
so they feel like they're only getting
matches when they when they've paid the
extra upgrade fee like i don't think
we're outsourcing many of our aspects of
our lives to our algorithms run by a
small number of people in silicon valley
for example i don't think that's
necessarily something we should just do
i think there's um
like nobody is new nobody who creates
these things is completely
you know they're not creating them
on a value-free basis it's not neutral
they have their own values and putting
it into that um for the benefit of their
company
and we should be careful i think in
terms of how we can engage with those
technologies or we should at least think
about it that
you know this may be someone else's
framework they're imposing on us when we
when we open an app
it's a really good point and one of the
things you've referenced a fair bit is
the manusphere let's let's talk
about men a little bit because and boys
particularly because
you're writing a book about it
and
correct me on this timeline but sort of
around the time of brexit and trump
there started to be this conversation
about you know jordan peterson became a
big figure
and
suddenly everyone was concerned about
men and men acting out and toxic
masculinity became this phrase and
and then you started hearing about the
incels and then there were these people
and then dating abs and all of this
seems to be there's like an emerging
narrative about it and there's genuine
problems emerging in that thing and i
remember cassie j's film the red pill i
don't know if you saw that
uh yeah i have yeah yeah yeah so all of
this was kind of happening in that time
and the conversation has moved on a
little bit but i feel like the issues
are only getting
more concerning not less in time where
are we with with men and men men acting
out as they say
i feel like with this with this subject
there's so i'm just reading nina power's
book which on masculinity which i think
is very interesting a very interesting
engagement with the topic i haven't
finished it yet
but i think um
books like that i feel are quite
constructive whereas i i've read other
books on this subject which i just feel
are deliberately inflammatory
they they take the worst examples from
different uh
subcultures and
define the entire subculture by by those
those unpleasant people
um i feel like the debate i feel like
there are two debates on this so we can
come here and i feel like we can talk
about it uh properly and we could have a
good discussion on it
um chris williamson you know his podcast
they also have some interesting
discussions on that and norma case's
podcast too the in-cell podcast
but then
you go to like liberal spaces and
it's like two completely different
conversations and i feel like both sides
could learn something but i feel like
the right does engage more with
well i'm not saying the right this is
like the right space but but i feel like
um
those outside of the mainstream tend to
be centrist here
those outside of the mainstream tend to
be better often at engaging with the
mainstream as well because you can't
really avoid it that's a good framing
mainstream and not mainstream i think is
the right yeah that's a better framing
you're right but i feel like i can i can
come here or i can i've been on chris's
podcast or the intel podcast and talk
about this issue and we can talk about
the nuances of why these young men are
being radicalized and it's not all just
like violent misogynist men some people
it's just men who are very depressed
but then none of that comes if if i try
and bring that conversation into liberal
spaces
it tends to be
you won't get commissioned
for the most part anyway but it tends to
be oh you're just making excuses for
insults you're just making excuses oh
like you're just saying poor men and um
there's it's just and it seems like a
nuisance why can't we talk about the
gender pay gap why that's that that's
the responsibility don't
we shouldn't talk about that let's talk
about um maternity leave and things like
that which is fine i think we should
talk about that but i think we can do
several things at once this idea that
you it's not a zero something you know
if we talk about say
uh the la the the declining numbers of
men proportionally going into higher
education which i think we should talk
about that that doesn't mean
that we can't talk about uh things
affecting women as well it just there
seems to be this zero-sum mentality that
you have oppressor and oppressed yeah
and therefore if you talk about male
homelessness for example
it's it's somehow a distraction from
talking about women's issues i think i
think on that particular issue that
mainstream space that you talk about
they they're stuck a little bit in that
oppressor press dynamic and really
the thinking is
reparations
that's what they're thinking about
they're thinking how low men have had a
this is their version in my opinion men
have had it great women have had it
terribly now finally we're making some
some progress we've got a bit of a
microphone we can talk about it it's
time to get our own back it's time to
advance our interest
and i think they're not thinking about
it in a holistic constructive way which
is what i'd like to do here in this
conversation so
why are
a minority of men but a growing minority
of men switching off that mainstream
dating society thing why is that
happening uh several reasons obviously
is a huge topic but for example i think
let's say start with dating for example
there have been huge changes
economically uh in terms of equality
between men and women technologically in
in recent decades which have meant that
the assumptions of our parents
generation and grandparents generation
in terms of romance have gone out the
window so i mean anyone who's ever tried
to go to someone older for for dating
advice um will know that how useless
that stuff usually is it's um the way
they met has uh
and even even monogamous monogamy and
monogamous marriage is you know the
numbers doing that are way lower than
they were back in our parents generation
uh
people can pick
uh women in particular can pick from
select from a much wider pool of
potential suitors now whereas in the
past due to the fact that they had less
economic women had less economic freedom
they tended to people tended to marry
locally anyway uh women tended to
they they tended to need to
marry someone who could financially
support them because there was no
guarantee that they'd be able to earn
a ways themselves for example
um so men who might not have much else
going for them had the fact that they
could could um
they had the whip hand over women in
terms of in terms of finances so they
could use that to control women within
relationships and also find a partner
like that dating apps allow give women
more freedom to choose from a wider pool
of people so
um if you're
an attractive young woman living in some
some village now you can get you know
some the back end of nowhere you can
still go on instagram uh build up an
instagram throw up a load of attractive
pictures and you'll get high status quo
quite men offering to take you out so
therefore the you know the guy down the
street who has the steady job uh in the
office uh or whatever is some suddenly
less uh attract a less attractive
proposition so i think that's that's the
thing
um
i i i don't say that's necessarily like
a
good or bad i think it's just something
that's happened um
and yeah i think also
uh
men's place in work via work has changed
men's relationship with work with with
production has changed massively so that
was hired something i looked at with
hired
men in the past working-class men in
particular would
there a lot of density would come from
work from making things from producing
stuff
from
those industries that existed
those have kind of been wiped away and
we tend to we've been sold this idea
that you should form your identity
through what you consume rather than
what you produce
but that's much more ephemeral i think
it's it's it's much shallower it's much
more easy to kind of
well it has it doesn't have the deep
roots if you're if you're producing
something you're making something
there's a certain pride of a sense of
accomplishment that you take out into
the world in terms of confidence whereas
i think for a lot of men
that they don't know their place in the
world because that's no longer there
they're no longer the breadwinner
they're no longer the someone who
uh has pride in being say a minor or
working industry or whatever it is
um it's much harder to get that as just
a wage slave in some like corporate
environment you just you do feel kind of
emasculated a little bit um some boss
like just ordering you around all the
time not that that didn't happen in the
old industries but
there is something
there's like a it's eroded a strong
sense of male identity i think and
couple that with the transformation in
the the dating market brought about by
these various things
it can be very confusing and you don't
have mainstream society you go to the
mainstream for a dating advice say and
it's garbage it's just be yourself
it's like i remember when i was
a teenager i'd i'd see that stuff and
it's just this this disney justified
nonsense you'll meet don't worry you'll
meet someone eventually like fate will
take care of it just be yourself just be
nice
and then you you go to the college party
or something and it isn't the nice the
nice guys who are like hooking up with
the with the with the with the girls
that you were into or whatever it's and
it's then you you feel like you've been
lied to and then you go in search of
pickup artistry or the manusphere or
you you look for things outside of the
mainstream because it feels like the
mainstream is
either lying to you with some agenda
either either from the date the
corporations like the dating apps or
or just some agenda or just some lack of
understanding and then you gravitate to
alternatives and some of those
alternatives are
not necessarily good for you you can
become radicalized by that i i was
watching uh that documentary what was it
the tinder
you know the tinder swindler exactly and
that was someone
who obviously went around and
exploiting women but what was very
interesting about it is
the guy presented himself as a
billionaire and the moment he did that
there was all these women wanting to go
to date him wanting to that's shocking
sleep with him but but the problem is
right no sorry
but the problem is is number one as my
girlfriend pointed out why would a
billionaire be on tinder yeah okay so
number two it's a number one that's a
problem and number two
we all want this unattainable lifestyle
we want the billionaire we want to live
this instagram lifestyle so the guy down
the street with a regular job who might
be a nice guy he might be a good guy
solid dependable have a good it's just
never going to be able to compete with
the fantasy
yeah i mean the the tinnitus window it
was it was a it was a great uh
documentary it was it was really well
done but the um and i i did feel sorry
for the women you know being ripped off
and stuff but there was a part of me
which was also like you could have just
swiped for a normal and a guy with a
normal
lifestyle i mean it's if something's too
good to be looks too good to be true it
pretty much always is
um
and so yeah i think it said something
interesting about people's expectations
of the type of partner you know they
deserve both men and women i think
that's a i think an issue there's an
issue of entitlement
um among
both men and women that we've been kind
of sold by
consumer capitalism whatever it is
that you deserve like the perfect
hollywood kind of uh
fairy tale uh romance and every aspect
of your life should be perfect so
you see men acting out um
more destructively than women because
men are much more likely to be violent
and uh you you do see you have this kind
of residual
misogyny which has just always been
there anyway james before we get into
that because i really want to ask you
about the manosphere can i ask you
you talked about how dating advice or
whatever doesn't really work
particularly from older generations i
suppose that if some i was just thinking
if someone asked me for a man asked me
how to get
get a girl i'm gonna ask you after the
show
i can help you
dr kk is gonna sort you out no but i
suppose the way i i i what i would say
and this is probably com completely
inappropriate now but is like don't try
to find a woman today but work on
yourself on your job on your personality
on your skills on your body whatever it
is that you think is going to make you
more attractive but really from for a
man it's about raising your status and
upping your game right
is that still not something that's going
to get you where you want to in the in
the current dating environment yeah i
mean i think that's your point is
interesting because uh that's something
that you do see people in say the red
pill community saying uh you know they
go off the deep end in about certain
things but there is that basic premise
of self-improvement work on yourself
which i think is a good a good starting
point um becoming a better but the
mainstream doesn't really talk about
that as much either it tends to tell you
um you're perfect as you are you know
someone will like you for who you are
which
which is i mean that is that is the
message oh someone should like you for
you and it's just yeah but there's
different versions of you right yeah
there's
yeah i mean there's there's there's the
i know from i you know i experienced
grief recently there's a version of me
which came out then which i wouldn't
want to
maintain
you know drinking at midday and and and
just not really doing anything it's like
a temporary thing but that's like one
facet of of me whereas you can be the
person who's doing stuff and yeah i
think status can it's still massively
important but in a way it's it's more
important how you present yourself so
you can have people who
uh have status say this applied before
dating apps as well say someone goes out
to a bar and is chatting to someone and
they're wearing like a rolex and their
first thing is oh do you like my rolex
or you know their flashing money that's
very unattractive but then if someone
discovers if the woman say discovers
later on
you know they they interact normally
then the woman finds out later on that
he has some high status thing it seems
more it seems cooler it's like show
don't tell yeah but i think with dating
apps you have to know how to present
yourself and if you you may be the you
may be jeff bezos or whatever but if you
don't know how to present yourself then
you're not going to do very well yeah i
can't remember who it was that said why
be yourself when you can be someone
actually worthwhile
i think but
to me that's that's always been the way
it's like you've got to get better man
that's that's and particularly for a man
if you want success in any field that's
what you're gonna have to do you're
gonna have to up your game simple as
that but let's talk about some of the
the problems that we're starting to see
that are coming out as a result this
because you talk about the manners for
you talk about incels
um is it a bigger problem are we just
talking about it more and what exactly
is the problem and i think
disenfranchised men essentially who feel
uh they've got no shot there's no chance
they're never gonna get a girlfriend
it's not going to happen yeah is that
how they feel yeah is is this fatalistic
you know forever they're going to be
forever alone is is something you it's
over you see in sales you hear the
insult saying it's just over it's over
bro
um i think it's wrong because i think
again transposing experiences of on apps
to real life whereas i think
those of us who grew up kind of one foot
in the digital world one foot out of it
so i my first mobile phone was like 17 i
think so so younger it was kind of you
grew up experiencing a different world i
think people coming up now
who've just uh had these experiences
mediated by apps i think that is
storing a big problem because it's it's
much harder to get those people to
recognize that
you know that's not the world like it's
just turn turn the app off go out let's
go out or something or go let's just
leave the house
and it's not always um as bad as it
seems on apps i think it is storing up a
big problem though i think you're seeing
this with uh
some of the resentments that are
spilling over from these communities
occasionally but i also think the
mainstream is dealing with it
very badly it's not really
um partly as a journalist partly i think
that's because
there simply aren't the resources in
journalism anymore there's more kind of
generalists who just
will suddenly write about say the insole
thing having just looked at it for kind
of 20 minutes before read some stuff on
it and they're churning out this uh
these hot takes on it and you just see
inflammatory pieces which aren't really
interested in examining
how this process of radicalization
happens just as we do with other forms
of extremism
it just tends to be like oh well they're
men they're privileged so let's just
like shut them down or ban their groups
or
yeah pretend it's not happening isn't
also the problem as well that society
has become more feminine
over the years and that look and that's
gone goes right the way through
education we could have a whole one-hour
podcast about why education has become
more feminine in a way it favors girls
more there's one simple statistic for
the same
for the same misdemeanor in school
boys are far far more likely to face
severe discipline than girls for example
that's interesting i didn't know that i
i know what you mean in terms of the
labour market so
uh the changes in the labor market for
example have become
more accommodating of women's uh i'd say
innate skills on average anyway
so it tends to be more service-facing
jobs where skills like communication are
valued more more highly so i think
that's obviously
um that's obviously had a had a massive
impact yeah
and there's also as well we're not
talking about the hormonal aspect of it
and
a really interesting article that you
wrote i think it was in the times we
talked about uh you talked about low
testosterone and the effect it's having
on men so let's explore that a little
bit what does it mean to have low
testosterone in a scientific sense and
what are the implications for men
yes sir so testosterone levels among men
in in
advance developed countries
tend to have gone down slightly in
recent uh decades i think it is it's in
my article anyway but
and there's no kind of well there's been
a steady decline over over many decades
hasn't there and it's essentially i mean
there are there are on in the minos fear
there are kind of conspiracy theories
about this and
uh there's also stuff that is a bit more
plausible about kind of contamination of
water supplies and stuff generally
yeah um
but but a lot of this is is um
is is kind of a cultural things really
it's it's i i don't think it's um
[Music]
yeah i don't think i don't think there's
there's a conspiracy i think it's
lifestyle and cultural factors so we
live more sedentary lifestyles which is
bad for your testosterone we're much
less likely to engage in
uh physical activity and
i mean
this is why one of the first things
during this article i went to interview
a doctor about uh who specializes in
this and he's like the first thing you
should do is like go to the gym and lift
weights because it's you're mimicking
some of the stuff you would have had to
do in the past um and that that kind of
improves your testosterone we don't get
enough enough sleep
uh because the kind of nights of the
office culture basically
uh the things we the certain processed
foods and stuff
all of this feeds the amount of time we
we sit on a script looking at a screen
um all of this stuff contributes to
having potentially low lower
testosterone which has a
hugely detrimental effect on all sorts
of things
people who are low testosterone
typically depressed
so it's not a good place to be
hey constantine do you believe every
business needs cyber security to succeed
yes of course because otherwise uncle
vlad will hack the hell out of it
wouldn't that be a gross violation of
international law in putin russia we
don't have law well if you don't live in
russia then pocket seam is the company
for you if you have a business that
needs protecting from the unscrupulous
elements of the internet then make sure
to check them out
unscrupulous elements that is no way to
talk about my family
pocket seam also provides free resources
if you follow them on twitter and
linkedin and if you want to keep costs
manageable you can also pay for their
services on credit pocketseem is the
best and most cost effective cyber
defense company in the world i tried
hacking them and all i got was
international sanctions if you want to
protect your company at a reasonable
price then go to pocketseam.co.uk
that's p o c k e t s i e m dot co dot u
k and get your company protected by the
best in the business
so
so let's explore that so what are the
signs for instance that you've got low
testosterone so we've touched on
depression which makes me which leaves
me horrified because there's people
there must be lots of people out there
who are on antidepressants lots of men
but actually the reason is they're
unloaded they've got low testosterone
and actually if they you know maybe took
testosterone supplements or they went to
the gym it would change their diet they
could completely change their lives yeah
i mean and and
getting yeah depression is often the
symptoms of low testosterone is often
mistaken for uh depression this was
something that came up in
my discussions with people who have been
diagnosed with it and taking
testosterone is like a last resort
lifestyle
like the legitimate doctors who do this
who work in this area will always
suggest testosterone is a last resort
because uh
it can re you can risk infertility uh
with that but it's also this is an area
where
you can't just tell whether someone has
high holy testosterone from appearance
we think it's uh oh well they may appear
very manly or they may uh so i couldn't
grow a beard very well until i was well
only just now i still still have a
patchy beard
when when it's growing i i couldn't
manage even that until like my mid-20s
and i was not like super like masculine
in school like playing rugby and stuff
um but so i would i got my my
testosterone was actually like fine it
was it was a good level but then you
have other people i spoke to i
interviewed for the article who
you would never think that they had low
testosterone but they were
and it took them a long time to seek
help because they were suffering with
these problems but they thought you know
i can't be it can't be this it'd be
depression uh low low or non-existent
libido um fatigue a brain fog
these kinds of things um so it's worth i
mean i think it's worth
anyone uh especially i'm 39 now i think
it's uh especially men around our age
it's worth getting checked out if you're
feeling symptoms of low mood for example
and what effect could that be having on
a broader section of society
um
i'm i'm not i mean
more people who are
depressed probably not good
yeah and i think it's um
the thing is
improving increasing your testosterone
corresponds with actually living just a
better lifestyle anyway so i think going
to the gym and lifting weights and
being healthier generally i think that
will improve
all different aspects of your life i
think you're more likely as a man to
meet a partner if you
get in shape get trim and stuff it's
like it incrementally increases your
odds a bit doesn't it
no it's
i i
when i read your article like i said i i
found it incredibly worrying because to
me you know we talk about mental health
and we talk about you know talking is
important and yes of course it is but if
you're not addressing the hormonal or
the biological then you're never gonna
not sort the problem out but deal with
it effectively yeah and i think i do
think um men and women deal with
problems in a different way
so
yeah i mean
we it feels like yeah it feels like
that's something that we have to pretend
isn't isn't really true now so i think
for many women many women like on
average i think there's great value in
talking about things for the sake of
talking about it yeah yes um
and you you know
anyone who's been in a relationship it's
like
knows that
your partner doesn't necessarily want
you to solve their problem they just
want to vent at you about it
and i think once you understand that it
makes relationships easier i think as as
men we tend to be
yeah it's like talk but i've been to
therapy and it's like all right talking
but but i want her to give me like a
road map so i can execute these steps
and and and make the change that way
like to me just talking about it doesn't
you know if we think of it like where's
the logical end point of it yeah it
needs to solve the problem as opposed to
just be a process that you go through
yeah that makes a lot of sense man so
the the
i'll be honest with you i feel like we
haven't really got deep enough into the
particularly the sort of like the
manosphere in cell resentment world
because i don't know anything about it
and
what's going on there james like what
what is brewing under the surface that
we don't know about
um i just think well you have the form
you have the formation of basically new
ideologies really so
and and conspiracy theories attached and
what are they what are those ideologies
one conspiracy theory for example i
would call it a kind of a conspiracy
theory it comes from something real so
dating apps we have the 80 20 rule which
is um
you know the pareto
uh distribution
rule where you know it's commonly
accepted and the stats by design that
on dating apps it's like 20 of men the
chad's so-called uh competing for 80 of
women are competing for them and then
the other 80 percent of men are
basically just being like ignored and
that is that is roughly true on dating
apps like tinder and hinge
but it becomes a conspiracy when it's
transposed onto real life so when you
have these black pillars
as they're called in the intel community
that's the ideology
they believe they'll never meet someone
because they take that
rule as something hard and fast that
they'll be
the 80 20 you know it's 20 percent of
men or less monopolizing
every woman in in the well 80 percent
of women in the world or whatever i
think that's a conspiracy theory which
leads people into
these very misogynistic our women are
just shallow women are just superficial
and these very misogynistic attitudes
and it's very simplistic view towards
women i think that's um
that's quite dangerous that creates
breezes hatred it's very deterministic
that women are like this men are like
this
stop seeing people as individuals um
and and when
radicalization like that takes place
and there is that
this neither you know the black pill
ideology for example
um very deterministic very fatalistic
teaches people that there's they have no
hope that the art it's like nihilism
basically and nihilism is always uh
can be done well it's always dangerous
it is especially for young men it'll
lash out is what's the point so what's
what's the counter argument to that to
that world view
in terms of in terms of the black
pillars and whatever what what do we say
to those people well i would say that
it's far too reductive for example so so
a black pillar would say that all that
matters in dating for a man is looks
all that matters is so that's why you
have that's just factually incorrect
though isn't it yeah i think it is but i
think i mean it matters way less than it
does for women yeah no i agree but it's
there in this echo chamber yeah where
they're they're telling themselves that
that's all that matters and there's kind
of an identity attached to being a loser
and i don't mean being a loser as that
person's like oh they're just a loser i
mean to losing they're they have an
identity attached to failure into losing
and
it's kind of like a bucket of crabs as
well so you have anyone who tries to be
slightly more optimistic or say actually
it's not as bad as um so i spoke to jack
peterson who used to be a
like spokesperson for the insults and he
was saying you know it's like anyone who
tries to improve themselves it's just
like what you're doing you're just
wasting your time it's just like
like small small town mentality or
something where you just kind of knock
down again do you not think this is also
about technology like 30 years ago
if you were a black pillar without
knowing it you
you didn't have access to 10 000 other
people who were exactly like you
and so you were surrounded by a world in
which you you constantly saw counter
examples your mate that you went to
school with it was a complete loser and
now he's got a great job and a beautiful
wife and three kids and whatever
like that was something that you could
see and you had to process that whereas
now you've got a forum of people who are
just reinforcing your beliefs about the
world so how much of this is just
technology more than anything yeah and i
think that's that's a good point in the
it's those niches are more accessible so
you can find your ideological niche
surround yourself for more and more time
with uh with with with like-minded uh
people who just reinforce that all the
time it's about selective focus as well
though because you know you can still we
can still
all of us find counter examples to we
could say that you know on average it's
it helps if you're if you're
good-looking or if you're taller
whatever as a man in the dating realm
but we all know
uh counter examples of
these other things
this person has it those things don't
matter
but i think
that's about if more and more of your
time is spent yeah on the technology
it's uh it's easier to shut it's easier
to have that selective focus where you
just focus on
uh
the ideology and any time anyone brings
up a counter example you just dismiss it
as well that's that's the exception
but isn't the problem as well let's be
fair there's a i've seen a lot of what
they write
there's an air of entitlement
to them they believe that they deserve a
woman who is a tenor or whatever is that
they call her whatever the terminology
is it's like well you're not entitled to
that particular person she doesn't
have to date you
and there's something deeply
narcissistic about it as well isn't
there oh yeah no i definitely think uh
doesn't like entitlement plays a
big part in in a lot of that i would say
not for everyone because you know there
are there are in cells i've spoken to
who they have you know severe facial
disfigurement and they're not they're
not expecting to
to to go out with kind of a playboy
model they just want uh
they just want some company at some
point they would just like to form a
relationship at some point
um
but i think at the same time there is an
element of
uh male entitlement in terms of uh some
people with their standards are just
like they they they don't want to
improve themselves or make any effort to
be kind of a better person themselves
they just want to be distinctly uh
average and yet they expect to find a
partner immediately who's who's amazing
it's just that's just not realistic
no
it's not
i think the thing that worries me about
the incels is that
again it seems to have been a movement
and correct me if i'm wrong it starts in
america and we've seen it with you know
the shootings particularly the one that
happened in santa barbara and california
which was that awful awful case
and so then went on to kill all those
young women and then it starts to bleed
over here do you think it's going to
become more and more prevalent
i mean i think some of the high profile
cases so um elliot roger
was was that one i think some of those
cases are slightly exceptional so he was
someone who clearly had a personality
disorder it's not just oh he's been on
some forums and that's made him do that
he's someone who clearly had at the very
least narcissistic personality disorder
if you watched his videos and read his
um his manifesto um and again there was
the incident in in plymouth here which
you know it was all when it when that
happened there were inflammatory comment
pieces and hot takes about oh this this
is why we need to crack down on uh
in-cell internet forums and then it
later transpired that it really didn't
have anything to do with with in-cell
ideology this was someone again who
a deeply troubled and i would say
probably
he had some troubled relationships with
women in his life so we might say yeah
he's he's has some issues with women
but i don't think i think it's a bit of
a stretch to then say that he was
radicalized by by these forums i think
the the
you i think there will be spillover
though it's not like i don't think
there's a risk of it but i think we need
to put it in perspective i mean most of
the people on these forums
uh
need help to get out of
depressed states usually to deal with
these kind of
uh mental health problems very often and
you have 25 of people on one of the
biggest insert forums who uh have some
form of autism
uh so it's it's not just you know people
being hateful for the sake of being
hopeful you have people with deep rooted
problems
and unfortunately sometimes that's
channeled into
radical ideologies just as we've seen
before with
uh with islamic terrorism we've seen um
you have some troubled individuals who
get drawn into these um subcultures and
radicalized we want to stop that instead
of just i mean we can denounce the the
acts and people will have it ultimately
a choice whether they go down this road
but we also want to understand it to
better prevent it i think i think it's a
really good point james and i sadly i
feel this conversation is only going to
get more important with time uh so i
look forward to your book when it's out
uh and we'll have you back and and and
get you to explain a little bit more
about this but for now thanks for coming
back where should people check out your
work follow you etc uh you can my book's
not out for a while but i'd be i'd love
to come back whenever it is anytime open
invitation brilliant uh
twitter jay underscore bloodworth on
twitter
james.bloodworth on instagram you can
read me in the new statesman and the
times and my book hired is is available
in all which we interviewed you about
before so go back and watch that if
you're interested brilliant book and it
was a really important piece of work at
the times why you exposed a lot of
wrongdoing though thank you that was
really important uh well thanks for
coming back james thank you for watching
and listening we're going to do a couple
of questions from our supporters for our
supporters for locals in the second uh
but in the meantime thanks for watching
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of which go out at 7pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
do you think dating advice gurus
actually make a real difference to
people are they just selling a dream to
themselves